hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel for those of you who saw when
I unboxed the Batman who lost a shoe
which is right next to me got my pride
and joy light of my life I was basically
like this is gonna sound and look bad
because my apartment is very small it
looks like I'm in my kitchen right now
so I am it's a studio apartment it's
only one room so the whole thing is sort
of a kitchen means it's difficult to get
angles Tong box things I also mentioned
audio being bad well today it's gonna be
even worse because it's the fourth of
July basically there's the whole thing
but I got this large box from CD Projekt
RED what could possibly be in it it says
a secret Omega cyberpunk it's a little
bit too long but you could see it no
actually we do know exactly what it is
it is the secret labs Saipan 2077
Edition gaming chair this comes at a
perfect time because I've had my buddy
HF for about four years and it's pretty
broken like this is handle here just
sort of whoever it once you know just
that's just one thing wrong with this
thing I guess I use it a lot but it was
you know it's probably about time that I
changed but also I've seen pictures of
this chart why it's very very very nice
I'm super annoyed so let's do it
[Music]
boxes inside boxes you say my favorite
sensing the problem what is this oh wow
congratulations you know the owner of a
brand new secret lab show just steps
away from your ultimate seating
experience flip the sheet over you will
find a Quick Start Guide to assembling a
secret lab chat oh that's real nice
well always things you can't do you try
and tell me I can't I can't canoodle on
this chair you know me secret labs do
not push the chair around when a person
is sitting in it that's like 50 percent
of the fun of owning a chair so that's
also a long do not place all your weight
only on the backrest how else am I
supposed to take naps ridiculous look
it's a lot flashier than my car you
definitely so spongy and in the back
that rolls got your headrest this one's
pretty plain the softest thing I've ever
felt to be fair I haven't touched a dog
in like two months
standards have changed wow this is also
really soft I'm super into this I can't
wait to sit on
[Music]
an accessories box
what oh this is miss Cruz got it on keys
screws and washes magnetic screwdriver
handle that makes sense that makes sense
okay we have everything out of the box
it's assembly time I guess by starting
with the legs
[Music]
yep that's the base of a chair great
love it okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we have like half a chip it's
happening ladies and gentlemen these are
magnetic makeover basically where I
screwed the top bit of the chatter the
bottom bit very nice stuff
[Music]
[Music]
okay pretty sure that's it shall we do
the honors whoo yeah it's comfy it feels
so much smaller than I the trip good
stuff I could sleep
I'm into this yeah that this is what
makes it tilt whoa
my other chanted I'll have a tilt
function and then you switched off to
stop it
yeah it feels good it feels good it is
so much I don't know why it feels so
much smaller the biochip I feel like I
can sit back in it forever
mm-hmm yeah
I'm into it this [ __ ] totally is small
like I felt like this chat is the the
head is higher and really wide and then
this is just like slimmer I feel like
I'm being hugged so I guess maybe it
would not be recommended to larger
people but for me it's way preferable oh
this is incredible I didn't know what I
was missing out on all this time you
know
turns out secret love make a good chair
give you guys a better look take this
off let's just secretly love that that's
yet you had rest good stuff what's up
very cool sign of funky details it's a
kind of looks like it's designed with
the cybernetics in mind yeah it's pretty
slim it like is very comfortable for me
but again don't know that it would work
for people who are a bit wider come
around the back so cool oh my god I love
it give myself a cyberpunk background
here and we are good to go alright thank
you everyone for watching another bad
unboxing and figure out what I'm gonna
do with this out the chair it's gonna be
a bit of a pain to get rid of and that
very large box but um story of my life
at this point really I'm alone and thank
you guys for watching and I will see you
guys next time